(audience cheering and applauding)
- Thank you.
I had to dress up for you.
- You look so good.
- Your audience is gorgeous.
- [Kelly] They're so
gorgeous and they're so fun.
- So colorful, yes.
- We like to run shiny here.
So wait, meet Terry, have y'all ever met?
- Yeah. We've never met. The first time.
- [Terry] We just did.
- Just met. Are you a sports ball fan?
- That's a good look.
- [Kelly] It looks so good, right?
- Yeah.
If I lose 60 pounds, I'm wearing that.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] You walked out.
- I gotta come here more.
(Brandon laughs)
(audience laughs)
- You walked out here. I was like okay.
(Brandon laughs)
But wait, so you went to the Emmy's
for the first time this
year? I did as well.
It was my first time.
- I saw you. I know. We
didn't know each other.
But I saw you.
- Well, it was my first time too.
I was a little nervous
'cause I'd never done that
and it was a long walk out there.
- [Brandon] It's a very long walk.
- Yeah, and did you have a good time?
- I had a wonderful time.
So, I was there with my best
friend who's on Rings of Power.
- And he was presenting Ismail.
And so we had this
incredible seat behind Oprah.
(audience cheers)
- Oh.
- Baby, baby. I left
my body. It was crazy.
She came out.
(Terry laughs)
I've never seen a white
jumpsuit that white in my life.
(audience cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
Right there. Ay, right there.
That's it.
- Oh, y'all were at the tables behind.
- We were at the table behind, yes.
That's me contained.
I was freaking out on the inside.
That's me really trying to be cute.
But that white, look at that white.
You ain't never seen
white like that, have you?
- [Kelly] First of all,
she like exudes special.
- That's a good look.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Hey, is that a pink watch, sir?
Is that a pink watch?
- Yes. I'm actually wearing it right now.
- Oh man, that's a good looking watch.
- Yeah, it's by this
Black-owned company called
Springbreak Watches.
- Yeah, that's nice. Nice.
- [Kelly] All right.
(audience cheers)
Here's what I was nervous about.
So I'd never done the
Emmy's, and I walk out
and then I was like, oh no.
Like I had just come from like
a big, huge shoot that day.
It was like, I came straight
from there, from another job
there, and I didn't know
all the tables were gonna be behind.
And I was like, wait, I made
sure the front looked good
but I dunno what the back looks like.
(audience laughs)
I was like,
"Oh, that's a whole lotta ass."
(Brandon laughs)
- You looked fabulous.
- I was like, well I don't know.
But I definitely wasn't
gonna be wearing white.
(Brandon laughs)
(Terry laughs)
I was like, woo.
She looked beautiful.
- [Brandon] She looked stunning.
Yes.
- So, yeah.
So wait, I wanna talk
about your new memoir
it's called "You Gotta Be You,
"How to Embrace This Messy Life
and Step Into Who You Really Are."
So, tell us about it, and
why you wanted to do it.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(Terry applauds)
- You know, I wrote the
book because I'm black,
I'm queer, I'm non-binary,
and I really wanted to create
a blueprint to self-love.
You know, if you're in any
kind of marginalized group,
loving yourself is a radical act.
You know, when you see representation
there's not a lot of representation
for those of us in these
marginalized groups.
And so we are taught
to, how do you survive?
How do you thrive in a world
that doesn't show you your value?
So I wanted to write my experiences
and really explore the question,
"Who would I be if society
never got its hands on me?"
So there's all these things
about, you gotta do this
you gotta be this, you gotta wear that,
you gotta act like this.
But what about being you?
And so this book is really
about how I learned to
step into myself and be
who I am, as opposed to who
society said I should be based
off the labels of my agenda.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(Terry applauds)
- Yeah. Wow.
I love that.
- [Brandon] Yes. Thank you.
- Well you didn't know a damn
thing about the other thing,
but you knew all about this.
(Brandon laughs)
- Knew 'bout my book.
- Kelly, if you're good with you.
- [Brandon] Yes.
- Isn't that the most important thing?
- [Brandon] It's the most important thing,
but it's the hardest thing.
- Right.
- It's the hardest thing
to like, when, again,
when you're in a world that tells you
that you're not good
enough because your race--
- [Kelly] Well and they
tell you what's beautiful
and they tell you what you should be doing
and they tell you.
I feel a lot of us go through that.
- [Brandon] Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- I think it's, I mean
I write it from my POV
as Black and queer, but
it's a story for all of us.
It's a universal story.
Every human wants to love
and to be loved, to be valued, to be seen.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- I agree.
- And so this story is about shaking
off what other people have
told you you should do
and figuring out what's good
for you and what you want.
- I like the idea too, just
shaking off any like, damage
if you wanna call it,
or just stuff, baggage,
that's happened in your life.
Just shaking that off and like being
who you really are capable of being.
That's nice.
- Yes.
Engaging with your trauma.
I say be messy, you know, like it's messy.
But engage with your trauma
so that you can actually thrive
with it and move forward.
Because the pieces of our trauma--
- Instead of repeating it.
- Yes. Because that cycle is real crazy.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Vicious.
- Interrupt the pattern.
Interrupt the pattern, yeah.
- Yeah, I agree.
(audience applauding)
- It's not easy to do.
No, it's not easy to do.
- Well, I'm hoping the book will be one
of the resources people can
use to get on that journey.
- I love reading stuff like
this, even if it's from a point
of view that isn't mine.
I think it's interesting
because it's also interesting
for me to know somebody
else's perspective.
So when you run into different
people, like you're like,
"Oh, I actually read about this."
Like somebody had this experience
and you're more understanding.
- Curiosity builds empathy.
If you can engage with other people's--
- Oh, I am so curious.
- Yes!
- To a fault.
- Of course, me too.
(Kelly laughs)
But that's why you got this platform,
because you are curious
and it builds empathy
and you're helping
other people get exposed
to experiences they wouldn't have had.
And now they're building empathy.
So when they do meet someone
like me, they're like,
"Oh that's a human
being," I'm a human being.
Thus, nothing human can be alien to me.
That's a quote by Terence.
That's what I live my life by.
- I love that.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Thank you.
- So, you're also in the animated series
Big Mouth on Netflix.
So what's happening?
- Yes.
So this season, season six,
is coming out October 28th
and we are focused on family.
Which kind of relates, you
know, all the trauma of family.
So all of our characters
have different things
that they're reckoning
with in terms of their
family.
- Especially like generational trauma.
- [Brandon] Hey, come on.
- Hey.
(Brandon laughs)
- Hey. Hey. We need another break.
Brandon's book, "You Gotta Be You"
is out now, y'all have to go get it.